[موسيقى]
اسمي أرييل ، أنا عامل google
يهودي عملت في google لمدة سبع
سنوات وقد استقلت الأسبوع الماضي بسبب
نمط الشركة في الانتقام
من العمال الذين يتضامنون
مع المجتمع الفلسطيني والذين
يتحدثون بصوت عالٍ  الحقوق الفلسطينية
مقلقة للغاية
ومثيرة للغضب بالنسبة لنا كعاملين ،
لقد حجبت الشركة عن قصد
المعلومات ، لذا فقد كانت
سرية للغاية بشأن الطبيعة
الفعلية للعقود ولكن هناك بعض
الأشياء التي نعرفها عن
العقد لذا  من الأشياء التي
نعرفها عن العقود هي أن Google
ستوفر تقنية ذكاء اصطناعي قوية
وأن المراقبة ستكون
إحدى حالات الاستخدام أم السبب الذي
نعرفه هو أنه كان هناك بالفعل
محادثة بين
مسؤول حكومي من  إسرائيل
وشخص من داخل فرق Google
تم الإبلاغ عن محادثة من خلال
اعتراض حيث كان هناك شخص تعرفه من
كان عميلاً  كان om داخل
الحكومة الإسرائيلية يسأل عما إذا كان من
خلال التكنولوجيا المقدمة من خلال مشروع
nimbus سيكونون قادرين على
اكتشاف ما إذا كان شخص ما يكذب ، لذلك كان من
الواضح حقًا أن هناك
حالة استخدام للاستجواب والمراقبة
كان يتم التفكير فيها في ذلك الوقت
و  أجاب موظف Google
بأنه نعم بشكل أساسي ، فإن أدوات وقدرات Google التكنولوجية الخاصة بنا
ستكون قادرة على اكتشاف ما إذا كان شخص ما يكذب ،
فهذا غير صحيح ، فنحن لا نمتلك
هذا النوع من القوة والإمكانات ، لذا
كان هذا في الواقع كذبة وكان  الأمر الذي يثير قلقًا عميقًا
بشأن
[الموسيقى]
هو أن ما يعنيه ذلك هو أن
Google تسلم
أدوات وتقنيات قوية للغاية إلى
حكومة وجيش معروفين على نطاق
واسع بتنفيذ الفصل العنصري
وجرائم الحرب ، لذلك كان
هذا أحد الأسباب القصوى للقلق
وما نعتبره أزمة
ضمير لا نعتقد كعمال
أن شركتنا التي تعد
أكبر محرك بحث في العالم  يوجد
شيء يجب أن يخدم حقًا
كصالح عام حقًا ، وهو
شيء يهدف إلى مساعدة الأشخاص في
الحكومة والجيش الذين
تعلمون أنه لا ينبغي أن يحدث
ولكن أقل من ذلك بكثير
[موسيقى]
لذا فإن اليوم الذي استقلت
فيه  مجموعة من 15 عاملاً في Google ، العديد
منهم فلسطينيون ، مجموعة من 15
عاملاً فلسطينيًا وأيضًا
عمال يهوديين مناهضين للصهيونية.
وشهادات
حول تجاربهم في العمل داخل
google وأنت تعرف كيف أن
Google لم تقم فقط بإسكات العمال الذين
يتحدثون عن هذه العقود غير الأخلاقية
في مشروع nimbus
ولكنهم يتحدثون عمومًا عن
ثقافة Google الراسخة بعمق في إسكات
وفرض الرقابة على
العمال الذين يتحدثون  دعماً
للحقوق الفلسطينية داخل
الشركة وأنت تعلم أن السبب وراء حديث معظم
هؤلاء العمال
دون الكشف عن هويتهم هو شركة du  على ثقافة جوجل
للرقابة
والانتقام ، حاول عدد لا يحصى من الموظفين
التحدث علنًا عن الانتهاكات
التي تعرض لها الفلسطينيون وتم
تجاهلها عمدًا ، لذلك عندما
تنشأ عقود عسكرية مبهمة مثل مشروع
نيمبوس ، أشعر وكأنني أعمل من
أجل الرجل السيئ حقًا  يخشى الكثير من
العمال أنهم إذا
تحدثوا باسمهم وبوجههم ،
فقد يتعرضون
للانتقام والسبب في اعتقادهم أن
Google لديها نمط واضح من
الانتقام ، فأنت تعلم أن العديد من العمال
الذين يشاركون شهاداتهم يشاركون بالفعل
القصص  من الضرر المادي الفعلي
الذي حدث في شكل
انتقام
[موسيقى]
الشعار التأسيسي لشركة Google هو "لا تكن شريرًا ،
ثم تقوم بالعكس تمامًا
هنا.
تأجيج عنف الفصل العنصري الإسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
لك